السؤال هو متى يكون مرآب السيارات
ليس مرآبًا للسيارات
والإجابة هي عندما يكون جزءًا من
نفق وشبكة مخبأ لاستخدامها في
حالة
الحرب وهناك دولة واحدة تهدد بأن
الحرب يحتمل أن يكون التهديد الكبير
روسيا
تومي راسك هلسنكي إدارة الإنقاذ في
المدينة  سنرينا حولنا ، لذا
إذا ذهبنا ورأينا المدخل الرئيسي على
ارتفاع 20 مترًا و 60 قدمًا تحت الأرض
مقطوعًا إلى حجر الأساس في هلسنكي ، فما مدى السرعة التي
يمكنك بها تجميع هذا معًا في حالة
72 ساعة و 6 آلاف شخص هنا ،
كم عدد الأشخاص الذين يمكنك استيعابهم في الملاجئ
قاعة helsinki uh أكثر من
تسعمائة ألف ،
وهذا يكفي للسكان بالإضافة إلى
الزائرين ، نعم نعم ، لقد قامت
الحكومة ببناء مخابئ هنا
منذ الستينيات
5500 في هلسنكي أكثر من 50000 في جميع
أنحاء البلاد
بما يكفي لـ 80 بالمائة من سكان البلاد البالغ
عددهم 5.5 مليون نسمة  نعم ، أعمق وأعمق ،
لكن حجمها ليس المفاجأة الوحيدة ،
فبعضها مفتوح للجمهور ،
ما
هذه لعبة وعاء الأزهار ، إنها مخبأ مع
sp  القاعة
يا إلهي
[تصفيق]
الكثير من الاستخدام المزدوج لموازنة التكاليف ،
لذا فإن هذا مثال واحد على
استخدامنا ثنائي الغرض للمأوى ثنائي الغرض ،
نعم ، نعم ،
الرياضة كل يوم من أيام الأسبوع
وقت الأزمة ما يحدث هنا في جميع الألعاب
الرياضية  البضائع عالقة بالطريقة التي بها كل
هذه الثقوب مقسمة إلى
غرف إيواء أصغر وليس فقط قاعات الألعاب الرياضية
ومناطق لعب الأطفال التي قد تكون
الأكثر أمانًا في المقاهي العالمية حتى
حمام السباحة فقط قاعة الإيواء
ولكن مع مسبح نعم
مع قارب أولمبي بحجم
أولمبي  الحجم حسنًا ، رائع ،
لكن كل شيء هنا مع غرض واحد في
الاعتبار ،
أبواب الانفجار ، حواجز الغاز ، مناطق إزالة التلوث ،
حتى الصخور التي يبلغ عمرها ملياري عام ،
أكثر من مجرد دليل على الانفجار ، لذلك إذا كانت
هناك قنبلة نووية ، فإن الصخر نفسه
يمتص الإشعاع ويبقي الجميع
هنا آمنين ، نعم ، هذا هو
الفكرة والأنفاق أيضًا
أنها منحنية بحيث تمنع أيضًا
بعض الانفجارات القادمة من خلال
تحقيق أقصى قدر من
الضربة ولا
إذا كانت ساحة انتظار للسيارات ، إنها ساحة انتظار سيارات مرة
أخرى
، هذا شعور غريب تمامًا ،
نعم ،
دقيقة واحدة كنت تستعد لجدار
في الدقيقة التالية تلعب الهوكي
،
والآن أصبحت ساحة انتظار سيارات ، نعم هنا يمكنك
رؤية مختلف اه  الطبقات وقبل
أن نغادر rask ، يُظهر لنا ملجأ آخر
بدأ للتو في حفر حفرة فيه وضع
المتفجرات في النفخ والمضي قدمًا ،
شكرًا لك ، وداعًا ، وداعًا ، وداعًا ،
تعال حركة المرور
هذه تبدو وكأنها مخرج
رائع للغاية ومثير
للفضول